Luke here the actor Boys YouTube channel
and I'm all by myself camping without a
tent in the wilderness of Alaska and
this is a great opportunity for me to
test a theory I've heard many times so
we're gonna find out whether heating up
hot rocks can keep you warm in the
winter time
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
check this out
if I'm not mistaken that's a bit of
porcupine you can see the little quills
right there porcupines are tasty if you
can get past the quills and looks like
something did
thank you
[Applause]
all right this seems like a nice fight
for camp
I think I better go find myself some
wood to build a shelter
foreign
at least eight dead trees about this
size that shouldn't be too hard
there's one I want to use dead trees for
my shelter not just because it's good
for the environment but they're lighter
to carry and they cut easier and then
the leftover pieces make better firewood
oh there's a good one right there
oh that's two good ones likely there's
lots of standing dead wood here we have
a beetle infestation here in Alaska
foreign
you sink a lot further down in the snow
when you have a log on your shoulders
I'm hauling all the small logs first to
try to beat a path so that when I haul
the big logs I don't sink down in the
snow as much
all right
oh it wasn't easy but I did it
I gotta tell you what guys I'm in love
with these boa bindings on these tub
snowshoes you can get them on and off so
quick even with your gloves on even when
they're covered in ice makes a massive
difference
well next step I need to pick a campsite
foreign
make sure it's strong enough
yeah that's good
foreign
Spruce bark Beetle that's what killed
the tree so probably killed all of these
trees
foreign
foreign
well I've got about 90 of my shelter
done but the sun's gonna set here in a
few minutes so I need to stop what I'm
doing and go get some more firewood so I
better hurry up and get everything
gathered around the camp well I still
have some light to see by
ah
[Applause]
I gotta get this fire lit and everything
is wet I got one of these little Zips
fire lighters
these things are awesome you can start
them with a ferrous Rod even if they're
wet so hopefully this will be enough to
get this wet wood started
thank you
it's burning slowly but it's burning
I'm gonna put my bed and shelter right
there and the fire there that way the
Smoke's blowing away from me and not
blowing into my shelter
foreign
we gotta get some River Rocks now
oh that's a fat one
[Applause]
now I know a lot of people say that if
you put River Rocks in a fire they'll
explode
yeah sometimes they do sometimes they
don't but uh we'll see what happens
foreign
well I got my shelter up including my uh
cot here it's a bit fidgety but man once
you get it up it is so comfortable it is
very warm in here and I've got a place
to sit and I'm not getting rained on and
the wind's not on me
pretty nice but I think it's time to
start making some dinner I am hungry
ah
nice cup of spiced orange herbal tea
with a load of sugar in it it's the
first calories I've had all day
that hits the spot
to get I got a big slab of pork jowl
bacon I'm gonna chop this up but we're
gonna make a stew out of it tonight
foreign
[Applause]
big jar of seasonings for the stew here
this has got vinegar salt pepper chili
powder mustard Dill oregano and a whole
bunch of other things
oh yeah
look at that
oh that is a good looking stew right
there yes I will take some of that
oh that's good all that melted Bacon Fat
mixed in with the vinegar just sweet and
savory and tangy
it's getting cold
gotta bundle up a little bit here
oh that was good time to do the dishes
I'm gonna stack up these rocks
make sure they're all nice and toasty
those piled up nicely well now they got
dinner out of the way we get breakfast
started I got some bread flour here and
I'm gonna make some bread dough
if I get it started now it'll be nice
and ready to cook with tomorrow morning
butter
all right I'll just put it somewhere
where it doesn't freeze and then they
used to do its thing and we'll have
bread dough in the morning
[Applause]
well I decided to get ready for bed and
I went to go pull out my sleeping pad
and it's not in my bag I had it clipped
to the outside and uh it's gone I think
it fell off sometime when I was in the
sled so we're gonna go see if we can go
find it before the snow buries it too
much
oh I took it out
[Music]
thank goodness
[Applause]
somebody put it on the truck they must
have found it on the trail and realized
it belonged to me since I'm the only
truck at the trailhead thank goodness
for good honest people I'm gonna sleep a
lot warmer tonight because of them
[Music]
[Applause]
I made it back but I am pretty wet
oh I was getting pretty worried there
I'm really glad I found that
oh my man is wet and I'm glad to have it
when I do this Bushcraft Cod I often
slide my mat in between the two layers
there but uh there's a bit of water
underneath this and I don't want to get
my down bag wet so I'm gonna go ahead
and stick this on top of my cot see if
that keeps me out of the water a little
bit better
there you go got my bed made up and the
fort button down as best I can now I'm
gonna show you what I'm gonna do with my
rocks
oh that's good
oh that's a good one
that's a good one
too
there you go the hot rocks are doing
their job you can start to see steam
coming off the cot
awesome
there you go I want I want dry firewood
in the morning
try to cover up my coals as best I can
so hopefully I'll have some dry warm
coals in the morning
got my logs and coals buried in Hot
Rocks so hopefully those will stay dry
until the morning
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
I'll see you guys in the morning okay
ah the only thing that can tempt me out
of this warm sleeping bag is the thought
of breakfast I really want breakfast
foreign
now my socks were a little bit wet last
night
I just took them off and put them in the
bottom of my sleeping bag and they're
all nice and dry and warm it's a nice
thing to wake up to
got a fair amount of snow last night had
about three inches of snow last night
before I went to bed and looks like we
picked up another half inch or so while
I was asleep let's see how our rocks did
in protecting our fire
[Applause]
I don't see any Embers
still feel a little bit of heat down
here
I think we might be able to get this
fire started if we use a lot of Tinder
uh oops that's that's all I got
that's that's not gonna cut it
all right
I'm gonna put a little gasoline a little
Bowl right there when you pour gasoline
on fire it kind of spreads out and goes
out really quick if you can put a little
jar or something it'll keep the flame
going for a long time
foreign
for like an hour and a half we get very
long sunrises and sunsets up north
well that bread Cooks I've got a little
jar of honey and butter I've sat by the
fire it's getting all nice melty yeah
that's going to be wonderful
you got the rest of this pork gel bacon
I'm gonna fry up to go with my flatbread
oh yeah
Bacon Fat melted butter honey
carb sugar and fat the three best
tasting things on a camp out
you know
I'm so covered in butter and grease it's
wonderful oh that was a delicious
breakfast but uh now they got a full
belly I think I need to clean up
all right I know a lot of you guys are
wondering about the rocks how did they
do
well every one of them is Stone Cold no
pun intended those rocks were honestly
not very useful they kept the bed warm
for about 30 40 minutes and after that
you just really couldn't tell they were
even there likewise the stones I piled
up on the fire were cold within a few
hours of the fire going out without
insulation a hot rock won't stay warm
very long even in mild winter conditions
like this
thank you
Oh what a beautiful cat I'm sorry but
it's time to go home
[Applause]
starting rough I'm no expert but that
looks like my choke is smashed up
[Applause]
that's not good all right I don't know
what I did but I did it
well that's why you always bring snow
shoes that thing don't start in the
morning you're walking home
I made it back to the truck but I can't
get inside the locks are frozen
all right gotta go old school
whoa oh
there we go
that's why they call me hot lips nobody
calls me that
[Music]
[Applause]
oh well that was fun and I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this video if you want
to see more camping videos from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel make sure
to see our camping Adventure playlist if
you want to see our more hardcore
survival videos check out our survival
camping playlist and don't forget to
click subscribe because we put out new
videos every Saturday morning we'll see
you guys then if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]